اه لم تسلم مياهه الخليجي من التهديدات
الايرانيه اذا اصبحت جزءا منها في العونات
الاخيره والدليل استهدف ناقله النفط قباله
خليجي عمان تهديدات كانت كافيه تلمضيه
واشنطن قد ومن في تسيير اكثر من 100 سفينه
مسيره في مياه المنطقه الاستراتيجيه بحلول
العام المقبل عبر قوه مخصصه للانظمه غير
الماهوله اذا اهم من هي او ما هي هذه
القوه المسؤوله عن هذه المهمه القوه 59
التي ستتولى نشر اكثر من 100 سفينه مسيره
هي اول قوه من نوعها تابعه للبحريه
الامريكيه تدمج الانظمه غير الماهوله
والذكاء الاصطناعي مع العمليات البحريه
الخامس وهو الذي يغطي ما يقرب من مليونين
و500,000 ميل مربع تشمل الخليج العربي
وخليجي عمان البحر الاحمر واجزاء من
المحيط الهندي
[موسيقى]